we're told a powerful magnet is
attracting a metal ball
on a flat surface the magnet is pulling
the ball
at a force of 15 newtons and the magnet
is 20 degrees to the south from the
eastward direction
relative to the ball here are a few
vectors where the magnitude of vector a
is equal to the magnitude of vector c is
equal to 50 newtons
and the magnitude of vector b is equal
to the magnitude of vector d which is
equal to 20 newtons
which vectors can represent the force of
the team's
pull all right pause this video and see
if you can
think about that on your own before we
do it together
all right now let's do it together so
before i even look at this i'm just
going to look at the description
it has a magnitude of 15 newtons if
we're talking about a force you could
view it as a strength
of 50 newtons and the magnet which is
pulling on the ball is 20 degrees to the
south
from the eastward direction relative to
the ball so if this is the ball right
over here
and if this is the eastward direction
it says the magnet is 20 degrees to the
south from the eastward direction
relative to the ball
so the magnet would be in this direction
and this angle right over here is 20
degrees
and the magnet is pulling on the ball so
the vector would go in that direction
towards the magnet
and we know it has a force of 15 newtons
that's the magnitude so it needs to be a
15
newton magnitude right over here so when
we look at the choices
choice a is interesting at least the
direction looks right
looks like it's 20 degrees south of due
east
and they also tell us that the magnitude
of a is 50 newtons
so i am liking a now let's look at b
well b looks 15 degrees south of due
east
not 20 degrees south so i will rule that
out and also b's magnitude
is wrong it's 20 newtons c
the magnitude is right it's 15 newtons
but the direction looks like 20 degrees
north of due east so i'll rule that one
out and last but not least
d the direction is clearly wrong it
looks like 15 degrees north of due east
and its magnitude is 20 newtons not 15
newtons
so i'd rule that one out now to be clear
a vector is only defined by its
magnitude and its direction
not by its starting point so if i had
some other vector that looked like this
right over here
that had the same magnitude and
direction if this was right over here a
20 degree
angle and it had a magnitude of 50
newtons then i would have selected
this one as well you can shift a vector
around like this
as long as it has the same magnitude and
it has the same direction it is an
equivalent
vector